Ah, I'll finish it soon, yes,
I love lies, lies, lies, Taro.
This is a dream. It's
because I'm trying to avoid reality. I'm talking
about Rentaro, and I'm just a B cup. But I'm
still a little bit of a B cup. I
like lies, I really like lies,
lies.  I love you so much, I love you so much, I love you so much, I love you so much, I love you so much, I love you so much, I love you so much, I love you so much, I love you so much, I love you so much, I love you so much, I love you so much, Lies, Lies,
Grandma blows me a kiss on the
other side of the river.  Are you
okay with people's self-esteem?
Oh, I'm
making the biggest deal about myself in the world. I'm
sorry, but I can't control the overflowing urges of love. But
now is not the time.
O.G.